[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute ist es so weit,
heute gibt es von mir ein Weihnachtsmenü,
was ihr euch gewünscht habt,
was sich aber auch der Murat gewünscht hat.
Und wenn es nach Murat ginge,
dann hätte ich einen Gänsebraten gemacht.
Und ich habe aber gesagt, das ist so gar nicht meins.
Also ich kann und ich will Gans auch nicht essen
und ich will es auch nicht zubereiten.
Mein Wunsch war ja auch einfach ein vegetarisches Menü,
was man auch superschnell vegan zubereiten kann.
Ich meine, ich bin keine Vegetarierin oder Veganerin,
aber ich muss sagen,
ich ernähre mich halt sehr viel von Obst und Gemüse
und habe wirklich einen ganz, ganz kleinen Fleischanteil nur.
Mein Mann, der sieht das Ganze immer ein bisschen anders.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, frage ich doch euch,
und habe auf Instagram eine Umfrage gestartet.
Und
es ist halt echt so,
also ich meine, viele sagen immer:
"Mach vegan" / "Mach vegetarisch."
Ach, 68% mit Fleisch.
Aber ich würde sagen, ich mache das jetzt heute.
Ich muss sagen, es ist schon
– ich darf das sagen als Türkin.
Das ist ein getürktes Weihnachtsmenü.
Denn es gibt heute Frikadellen, also Köfte.
Und ich werde das so machen
– ich finde nämlich, bei einem Menü,
egal, ob an Weihnachten, an Ramadan
oder wann auch immer, zu welchem Anlass auch immer,
ist mir ganz besonders wichtig,
dass man zum einen stressfrei kocht,
dass alles gleichzeitig fertig ist,
wenn man nicht gerade
Vorspeise, Hauptspeise, Nachspeise macht,
und dass man eben einfach von der Organisation her
alles einfach hat.
Also gibt es heute Frikadellen.
Später gibt es noch ganz viel Gemüse und viele Beilagen.
Und ich zeige euch das jetzt so,
wie ich es jetzt vorbereiten würde.
Los geht es mit den Frikadellen.
Dafür verwende ich Lammfleisch.
Ich habe hier zwei Fenchelknollen,
zwei Knoblauchzehen,
ein bisschen Petersilie.
Ich brauche etwas Zitronenabrieb,
ein Ei,
Salz, Pfeffer und Kreuzkümmel
und etwas Semmelbrösel.
Ich nehme jetzt hier Lammfleisch.
Ihr könnt aber auch Rind nehmen
oder welches Fleisch ihr eben bevorzugt.
Und wenn ihr das Ganz vegan zubereiten wollt
oder vegetarisch, könnt ihr ja auch einfach Linsen benutzen
oder Nüsse gehen auch.
Also man kann Frikadellen mittlerweile
wirklich sehr, sehr gut auch vegetarisch zubereiten.
So. Das Erste, was ich machen werde
– wie gesagt, ich mache das Hackfleisch oftmals selber.
Hier kommt jetzt Fenchel mit rein.
Da nehme ich hier in der Mitte
diesen Strunk raus.
Den kann ich noch benutzen, um mir einen Tee zu kochen.
Denn ich liebe Fencheltee!
Da nehme ich den dazu und dann noch Anis
und Kümmel oder Fenchelsamen.
Dann schneide ich den jetzt grob.
Wenn ihr nicht mit dem Fleischwolf arbeitet,
dann könnt ihr den jetzt auch raspeln
oder ganz, ganz, ganz fein hacken,
falls ihr schon fertiges Hackfleisch verwendet.
Aber ich zerkleinere jetzt alles gleich darin.
Das ist eigentlich immer ganz praktisch.
Und so auch für Veganer oder Vegetarier ist ein Fleischwolf
– es ist halt nicht nur ein Fleischwolf,
es ist ein Alleszerkleinerer.
Der zerkleinert wirklich alles.
Auch, wenn man mal zum Beispiel Falafel machen will,
zerkleinert er supergut die Kichererbsen
und eben auch alles weitere.
So.
Dann habe ich das schon mal erledigt.
Und dann kann ich im Prinzip
– ja, das kommt auch dazu, die Petersilie.
Und dann kann ich jetzt das Fleisch zerkleinern.
Und das schneide ich jetzt nicht in Würfel,
sondern in lange Streifen.
Denn dann hat es der Fleischwolf einfacher,
sich diese Streifen zu nehmen
und vorne eben zu zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Das Fleisch habe ich jetzt kurz aus der Schüssel raus.
Denn ich habe jetzt eine größere Menge gemacht,
den Rest friere ich ein.
Ich nehme mir später die Menge, die ich brauche.
Was ich aber jetzt machen werde:
Ich werde, wie gesagt, noch das Gemüse zerkleinern.
Und das hat auch den Vorteil,
dass das restliche Fleisch, was hier noch drin steckt,
einfach mit rausrutscht.
Dann hat man da einfach null Lebensmittelverschwendung.
Nur, beim Gemüse muss man ein bisschen mitdrücken.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, meine Mama, die hat so ein Trauma
vom Fencheltee, den man so nach der Geburt gekriegt hat
für zum Stillen,
damit Babys
– Babybauch und so weiter.
Und ich glaube, nach fünf Kindern und so viel Fencheltee
verging ihr der Appetit auf Fenchel.
Und ich habe die Liebe zu Fenchel aber frisch entdeckt.
Also ich liebe Fenchel.
Huch!
Die Knoblauchzehe kommt auch mit rein,
aber wird zerkleinert.
Und falls ihr statt Semmelbröseln altes Brot nehmt,
also so ein bisschen trockenes,
könnt ihr das jetzt auch noch mit da reingeben.
Also man kann wirklich alles zerkleinern.
So.
Das war es.
Jetzt nehme ich einfach meine Menge rein, die ich brauche.
Ich lege es ganz liebevoll rein.
Und den Rest friere ich einfach in einem Gefrierbeutel ein.
Das mache ich gleich
und werde jetzt hier aber das Ganze noch verfeinern
mit
– was holt sie jetzt? Was holt sie jetzt? –
etwas Zitronenabrieb.
Aber wirklich nur eine kleine Prise.
Dann ein Ei für die Bindung.
Salz.
Pfeffer.
Und was ich in Fleischgerichten immer total gerne habe,
ist Kreuzkümmel,
Kumin auch genannt.
Und dann noch ein bisschen
– weil der Fenchel und die Petersilie sehr nass sind,
ein bisschen Semmelbrösel.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich jetzt alle brauche
oder nicht.
Und dann dürft ihr es einfach verkneten
oder kurz mit der Maschine verrühren.
[Musik]
So sieht das schon mal perfekt aus.
Und es riecht vor allem sehr, sehr, sehr gut.
Und jetzt kann ich die Masse hier abdecken
und für eine Stunde in den Kühlschrank stellen.
So kann sie noch mal gut durchziehen.
Ich mache noch kurz eine Geschmacksprobe.
Das heißt, ich nehme eine kleine Menge
und gare die in der Mikrowelle zum Beispiel.
Dann weiß ich auch, ob ich genug Salz mit drinnen habe.
Denn roh probiere ich das immer nicht so ganz gerne.
Und dann geht es direkt mit den Beilagen weiter.
Also hier dazu kommt jetzt noch
so gerösteter Fenchel.
Den bereite ich kurz vor.
Dann habe ich den Part sozusagen erledigt.
Und dann geht es gleich an die anderen Beilagen noch.
Weiter geht es mit der Gemüsebeilage.
Ihr könnt da im Prinzip Gemüse nehmen,
was euch einfach am besten schmeckt.
Ich nehme ein bisschen Wintergemüse,
das heißt Rosenkohl,
Karotten,
Rote Bete.
Hier habe ich noch einen Porree
und Blumenkohl.
Aber, wie gesagt, ihr entscheidet selbst.
Und das bereite ich jetzt auch so vor,
dass ich es später eben nur noch anbraten muss.
Das heißt, der Rosenkohl
– also alles ist schon gewaschen.
Bei dem muss ich im Prinzip
da unten so ein bisschen was wegschneiden,
vielleicht die äußersten Blätter wegnehmen.
Und den werde ich dann halbieren.
Rosenkohl ist immer ganz gut,
wenn er so den ersten Frost überstanden hat.
Dann schmeckt er nicht mehr so bitter.
Und ich mag es gern.
Murat hasst es, aber ich mache es trotzdem.
Ist mir egal.
Dann esse ich seine Portion.
Wenn ich zu Ela am Tisch sage:
"Wenn du Gemüse isst, dann wirst du groß und stark",
dann guckt sie immer zu Murat rüber
und dann
isst sie es immer ganz schnell.
[Musik]
So.
Jetzt halbieren.
Oh, guck mal, wie schön!
Sieht doch schön aus.
[Musik]
So. Die Karotten, die schäle ich jetzt auch nicht.
Das sind nämlich Bio-Karotten.
Da lassen wir schön die Schale dran.
Und die schneide ich jetzt
– wie schneide ich die, dass sie hübsch aussehen?
Ich schneide sie so diagonal.
[Musik]
Den Porree schneide ich so.
Und der Part hier vorne, der ist oft gar nicht sandig.
Aber hier in der Mitte muss man schon ein bisschen gucken,
Da kann es sein, dass er noch sandig ist.
Nee.
Aber der da hinten auf jeden Fall.
Und das Dunkle hier, das nehme ich gar nicht.
Ich glaube, den packe ich sogar komplett weg.
Den nehme ich dann einfach für die nächste Gemüsebrühe.
Und das wasche ich kurz und das kann ich noch nehmen.
Der Blumenkohl, der ist ja schon bereit.
Und jetzt nur noch die Rote Bete.
Ich nehme Handschuhe.
Denn sonst habe ich rote Hände.
Und die Rote Bete, die könnt ihr dann schälen
und eben auch in Spalten schneiden.
[Musik]
Und die lagere ich jetzt aber hier separat,
damit sie das andere Gemüse nicht verfärbt.
Und das packe ich jetzt auch zur Seite
und das ist jetzt bereit für später.
Das könnt ihr auch am Abend vorher zubereiten
oder direkt morgens oder mittags.
Dann habt ihr das auch schon bereit.
Abdecken am besten.
Die Männer in der Runde, die haben gewonnen.
Denn jetzt gibt es noch kleine Kartoffelpfannkuchen
oder auch Latkes genannt.
Die gibt es auch in der israelischen Küche.
Da ist es auch so ein bisschen
– ich meine, das sind halt Kartoffelpuffer.
Ich mache sie jetzt nicht rein nur aus Kartoffeln,
sondern ich nehme Kartoffeln,
Pastinaken,
eine Zwiebel
– ich habe jetzt hier eine halbe, weil die recht groß ist.
Etwas Schnittlauch hatte ich noch im Tiefkühlfach.
Ein Ei,
etwas Stärke,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Und was ich jetzt hier machen werde:
Ich werde jetzt erst mal die Kartoffeln reiben
– da könnt ihr entweder eine Handreibe nehmen
oder auch eine Küchenmaschine –
und werde sie in einem Tuch so ein bisschen auspressen,
damit sie eben nicht mehr so nass sind.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich hier ein sauberes Geschirrtuch.
Also ich war ja dafür,
dass wir einen Fenchel-Kartoffel-Auflauf machen dazu,
so was Schönes, Leckeres, Warmes für den Bauch.
Aber ich meine, so Kartoffelpuffer
sind halt schon auch lecker,
muss ich zugeben.
Okay.
Dann könnt ihr das nämlich hier nehmen
und so ein bisschen ausdrücken
am besten über dem Waschbecken.
Und wenn ihr das dann so ein bisschen liegen lasst,
dann trocknen sie auch noch ein bisschen.
[Musik]
So.
Aber das lasse ich jetzt erst mal hier liegen.
Puh!
Oder ihr nehmt einen Entsafter.
Die Pastinake und die Zwiebel werde ich auch so zerkleinern.
Und dann im Prinzip einfach nur alles kurz verrühren.
Und dann ist die Masse auch bereit.
Ah, das geht doch fix.
So macht das Weihnachtsmenümachen Spaß.
Ihr müsst natürlich dabei Weihnachtslieder hören.
Das ist ein Muss.
Ich darf aber nicht, sonst wird das Video gesperrt.
Sonst hätte ich das schon lange gemacht.
[Musik]
Krass! Sieht aus wie Käse.
Wie so Reibekäse.
Ich muss echt sagen, die Pastinake,
das ist echt so ein Gemüse, was oft unterschätzt wird.
Und bis ich die Samira hatte,
habe ich noch nie Pastinake gegessen
und kam dann erst so durch die
Babykosteinführung sozusagen
in Berührung mit Pastinake.
Und seitdem mag ich es voll.
Ist schon lecker.
So. Die Kartoffeln kommen jetzt wieder dazu.
Oh, man hätte auch eine größere Schüssel nehmen können.
Ich habe noch gedacht: "Soll ich die große nehmen?"
Dann dachte ich: "Nö, das reicht."
Und jetzt alles vermischen.
Und jetzt hier ordentlich würzen.
Denn die Kartoffeln, die vertragen schon
recht viel Salz und Pfeffer.
[Musik]
So. Dann habe ich das jetzt auch bereit.
Ich stelle es zur Seite
und kümmere mich jetzt wieder um die Frikadellen,
um die Köfte.
Ich kann jetzt schon mal die Frikadellen formen.
Ich nehme einfach ein bisschen Olivenöl
so in die Hand.
Dann einen Eisportionierer,
ich nehme jetzt den mittleren.
Und guckt mal, jetzt ist die Masse auch schön fest
und schön durchgezogen.
Ich hoffe, dass es jetzt passt mit dem Salzgehalt.
Aber ich habe es ja eigentlich schon probiert.
Und die forme ich jetzt und lege sie hier rein.
So sind alle schön gleich groß.
Oder sollen wir sie größer machen?
Ach, nee.
Das passt.
[Musik]
So sehen sie jetzt aus, richtig gut.
Dann werde ich jetzt noch hier den Fenchel verarbeiten.
Hier oben die trocknen Stellen ein bisschen wegnehmen.
Dann
halbieren und auch hier wieder
diesen Strunk entfernen.
Und dann könnt ihr den Fenchel
einfach so schneiden,
schön grob lassen.
[Musik]
Ich wollte ja eigentlich so ein Menü für vier Personen machen,
aber es eskaliert gerade wieder.
Das würde nämlich bedeuten,
dass jeder eine Fenchelknolle isst.
Ich glaube, vier sind doch zu viel.
Ja.
So. Und jetzt werde ich es so machen:
Ich habe jetzt lange hin und her überlegt,
aber ich bin zum Entschluss gekommen,
dass ich die Frikadellen jetzt nicht anbraten werde.
Zum einen ist es nämlich viel, viel besser zum Vorbereiten
und zum anderen riecht das ganze Haus
nicht nach gebratenen Frikadellen.
Das wird jetzt ein Ofengericht.
Also ich hätte es sowieso im Ofen gegart,
ich wollte sie nur kurz,
damit sie knusprig werden außen, anbraten.
Ihr könnt das machen, ihr müsst aber nicht.
Ich mache es jetzt so:
Ich gebe ein wenig Olivenöl hier in den Bräter.
Ihr könnt einfach eine Ofenform benutzen.
Das, muss ich sagen, spare ich mir so ein bisschen jetzt.
Ich mache das so wie bei meinem Ofenkebab damals.
Da habe ich dann auch die Frikadellen geformt
und dann eben einfach im Ofen gegart.
Und dann ist echt der Vorteil, dass ihr es wirklich
auch schon am Tag vorher sogar vorbereiten könnt
und dann vor dem Essen
nur noch reinschieben müsst in den Ofen.
So.
Dann gebe ich jetzt hier
einfach den Fenchel und die Frikadellen rein,
schön bunt gemischt.
Okay, das Gericht heißt Frikadellen auf Fenchelbett.
Okay, es war vielleicht zu viel Fenchel.
Mein Gott!
Das passt doch.
Das passt alles rein.
Ihr könnt auch weniger Frikadellen machen,
weil das ist auch für vier Personen ein bisschen viel.
Dann ist es okay.
Der Josh sagt nämlich immer, ich mache
bei meinen Mengenangaben
– wenn ich vier Personen sage, sagt er immer zwei.
>> JOSH: Manchmal ist es irgendwie so ein bisschen,
ja, knapp bemessen
>> SALLY & JOSH: und manchmal
>> JOSH: rastest du komplett aus.
>> SALLY: Manchmal raste ich aus. So.
Okay.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte ursprünglich nur 500 Gramm nehmen
und bin dann auf 700, aber es war vielleicht doch 500.
Na ja, egal.
Jetzt kommt hier noch etwas Brühe drüber.
Da könnt ihr jetzt Gemüsebrühe nehmen oder Fleischbrühe.
Ta-daa!
Noch ein bisschen Salz, Pfeffer drüber,
damit der Fenchel auch ein bisschen Gewürz abbekommt.
Und dann ist dieses Gericht, wie gesagt, auch vorbereitet
und es kommt später einfach nur noch in den Backofen.
Und wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr sogar
kurz vor Ende der Garzeit
ein bisschen die Grillfunktion einschalten.
Dann bekommen die Frikadellen
von oben noch eine schöne Bräune.
Ich werde das jetzt aber erst gleich machen,
wenn alles andere auch fertig ist.
Denn ich kümmere mich jetzt
zum einen noch um die Gemüsepfanne
– oh, nee, ich mache jetzt erst noch die Tahinsoße.
Denn es gibt noch eine Soße.
Jetzt machen wir noch eine Tahinsoße.
Tahin ist einfach eine Sesampaste.
Und die gibt es auch oft in der marokkanischen,
israelischen, arabischen, türkischen
– in vielen Küchen.
Und das ist einfach die pure Sesampaste.
Das ist jetzt eine geröstete, daher ist die dunkler.
Und die wird jetzt verfeinert
mit Knoblauch,
Zitronensaft,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Und ich nehme jetzt eine Knoblauchpresse.
Dann muss ich nämlich den Knoblauch gar nicht schälen.
Ui!
Knoblauch spritzt durch die Küche.
Okay.
So.
Da kommt es halt echt auf das richtige Abschmecken an.
Also ich finde, da muss es so eine schöne Säure haben
aus den Zitronen.
Ich habe jetzt hier Zitronen mit viel, viel Zitronensaft.
Ich glaube, ich nehme erst mal nur eine.
Dann eine ordentliche Portion Salz und Pfeffer.
Das richtige Maß an Knoblauch,
was ich gerne mal überschreite.
Und dann einfach mit Wasser verdünnen.
Da könnt ihr auch warmes Wasser nehmen.
Dann geht es etwas einfacher.
Und dann ist das im Prinzip schon die fertige Tahinsoße.
Und die ist ganz oft auch in
– kennt ihr Schawarma?
Kennst du das, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: So... Oh!
>> JOSH: O Gott!
>> SALLY: Wir müssen mal Schawarma machen.
Das ist schon lecker.
So.
Und sobald das jetzt verrührt ist,
schalte ich den Ofen an,
packe mein Köfte in den Backofen,
gehe an den Herd
und mache die Gemüsepfanne
und die Röstis, also diese Kartoffelpuffer.
Ja.
Jetzt ist nämlich alles bereit.
Wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt noch einen Salat dazu machen,
wäre jetzt auch die perfekte Zeit, um den Salat vorzubereiten.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe jetzt genug Gemüse
und genug an Essen.
Jetzt geht es ans Fertigstellen.
Zeig einmal.
Ah, ein bisschen zu dünn.
Ich brauche doch noch mal ein bisschen Tahin.
>> JOSH: Unten ist relativ viel noch fest.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ist heute der Tag der großen Sauerei?
>> JOSH: Er ist es.
>> SALLY: Er ist es.
[Musik]
Hier geht es jetzt an die Gemüsepfanne.
Dafür nehme ich ein bisschen Olivenöl
und einen großen Bräter
und etwas Butter.
Die Butter ist optional, müsst ihr nicht nehmen.
Und da wird jetzt im Prinzip
erst einmal die Rote Bete angebraten.
Dann schiebe ich die auf die eine Seite mal rüber.
Und dann das übrige Gemüse.
Und das schmecke ich später
einfach mit Salz, Pfeffer und einer Prise Zucker ab.
Und dann habe ich eine richtig schöne Gemüsepfanne.
Jetzt nicht zu heiß anbraten,
sondern eher auf mittelhoher Hitze,
so auf 7 von 9.
Da lacht der Josh.
Und dann habe ich später ein schönes knackiges Gemüse,
was eben tolle Röstaromen hat.
Und hier werde ich in der Pfanne
– da habe ich jetzt schon ein bisschen Sonnenblumenöl.
Olivenöl geht aber auch.
Und ich kann jetzt hier mit dem Eisportionierer
und dieser Masse
einfach diese kleinen Küchlein ausbacken.
Und ich drücke das dann gerne
einfach so in den Eisportionierer rein.
Dann zwischen den Händen so zusammenpressen
und hier bei mittlerer Hitze schön ausbacken.
Ja.
Und wenn ihr das jetzt so parallel ein bisschen beobachtet,
habt ihr alle drei Gerichte gleichzeitig fertig.
Ich portioniere alles mit einem Eisportionierer.
Ein Leben ohne Eisportionierer geht,
ist aber sinnlos.
[Musik]
Also jetzt ist das Menü fertig.
Wie gesagt, haben wir hier die Köfte-Pfanne,
Gemüse,
Tahinsoße
und Kartoffelpuffer.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich muss sagen,
gerade so vom Organisationsablauf her
alles super vorzubereiten.
Und dann habt ihr euer warmes Essen schön auf dem Tisch.
>> MURAT: Ja. Also
ihr werdet ja so ein Weihnachtsmenü
so ähnlich feiern jetzt wie wir,
nur
– also wir haben noch kein Weihnachten.
Das ist jetzt nur gedreht.
Wir sind also in so einem IKEA-Einrichtungshaus.
Zum Beispiel.
Und diesen Mann haben wir auch gefunden.
Das ist der Papa.
Der ist auch da.
>> SALLY: Passt perfekt in die Familie.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Weil wir haben – brauchen immer zwei ehrliche Menschen.
Kinder sind immer ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Sie ist halt lieber die Fenchelknolle.
>> MURAT: Isst sie gerade den Fenchel auf?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ela, isst du gerade den Fenchel?
Zeig mal den Zuschauern, wie der Fenchel aussieht.
>> SALLYS PAPA: Der schmeckt ihr.
>> MURAT: Weil das wissen die wenigsten.
Und das kann man so essen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und wir haben draußen Fenchelgewürz
und das liebt Ela auch, gell?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das ist gut gegen Bauchschmerzen.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Küçük keçi gibi.
Wie so eine kleine Ziege.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Okay. Dann probieren wir es mal aus.
>> SALLY: Also probiert mal.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: So.
Also gib mal kurz Papas Teller.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Da hast du Fenchel.
>> MURAT: Und Fenchel ist wirklich so was,
wo man unterschätzt eigentlich, gell?
>> SALLY: Ja, total.
Und ich finde, Fenchel schmeckt so würzig.
>> MURAT: Ja. Warte kurz.
Mmh!
Ich mag Fenchel über alles!
Wie konnte ich nur ohne Fenchel die ganzen Jahre leben?
>> SALLY: Und ich muss sagen, ich habe hier jetzt gerade
das Gemüse und alles so ein bisschen
– ja, wie sage ich? –
naturbelassen.
Denn die Tahinsoße hat schon gut einen eigenen Geschmack.
Und ihr könnt natürlich würzen, wie ihr möchtet.
Ihr könnt noch Kräuter mit dazu geben aus dem Garten.
Also macht gerne alles so, wie ihr das wollt.
Die Kartoffelpuffer solltest du mal probieren.
Denn die habe ich mit Pastinaken noch gemacht
und die geben dem Ganzen
noch einen richtig guten Geschmack.
Also probiert gerne Teile des Menüs aus
oder auch das komplette Menü.
Schreibt mir gerne,
was es bei euch dieses Jahr zu Weihnachten gibt
und was es vielleicht traditionell bei euch gibt.
>> MURAT: Ich finde Raclette immer cool.
Mit Raclette kannst du nie was falsch machen.
>> SALLY: Raclette ist auch cool.
Aber ich bin halt so voll Gemüsefan.
Deswegen feiere ich dieses Menü,
weil so viel Gemüse enthalten ist.
Also macht's gut!
Kocht was Schönes
und schreibt uns gerne euer Feedback.
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Enjoy!
>> ELA: Das hat nämlich schon ganz geschneit.
>> SALLY: Iss doch mal so für die Kamera.
>> MURAT: Ja, so.
>> SALLY: Nicht...
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Hallo, mein Name ist Max Mustermann
und es schmeckt so toll in unserer Musterküche.
Das ist meinen Musterfrau.
Das ist mein Musterschwiegervater.
Und unser Musterkind kommt auch gleich.
Ich wünsche euch Frohe Weihnachten.
War das so in Ordnung?
Kann ich jetzt essen wie ein normaler Mensch?
>> SALLY: Dann iss halt.
>> MURAT: Papa, schmeckt es?
>> SALLYS PAPA: Schmeckt gut.
>> MURAT: Ja. Es ist auch deine Tochter,
du würdest auch nichts anderes sagen.
>> SALLYS PAPA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Hier sind alle ehrlich.
>> ELA: Ich gehe kurz nach draußen.
>> SALLY: Mhm!
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> ELA: Doch!
>> MURAT: Du kannst nicht nach draußen,
weil draußen ist ein furchtbarer Wirbelsturm,
weil es ist Weihnachten und es schneit
und wir sind eingeschneit.
>> ELA: Warte. Ich gucke mal.
>> SALLY: Das ist der Grinch.
>> ELA: Hier ist kein Schnee!
[Musik]